Salut, aujourd'hui on est mercredi c'est le jour de l'astuce.
Et encore plus qu'une astuce aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'un concept
qui est la zone de confort.
La zone de confort c'est tout l'univers dans lequel
vous évoluez, vous vivez en ce moment.
Qu'il s'agisse de votre travail, de vos amis, de votre famille,
de ce que vous aimez faire, de la manière dont vous vivez,
de ce que vous faites pour vous détendre...
Tout est inclus à l'intérieur du cercle.
A l'extérieur du cercle, il y a tout ce que vous aimeriez peut-être faire dans votre vie,
que ce soit des choses délirantes comme sauter en parachute habillé en Luigi,
aux ambitions professionnelles et aux ambitions personnelles.
On peut d'ailleurs représenter tout ça par d'autres petites bulles.
Et les croix, elles symbolisent le danger, elles symbolisent l'inconnu,
elles symbolisent aussi la prise de risque.
Mais quand vous sortez de votre zone confort,
quand vous allez un petit peu vers l'inconnu,
et que vous réussissez à faire ce que vous avez entrepris au départ,
alors votre zone de confort augmente : elle s'élargit.
Et c'est là le but de cette astuce :
pour évoluer, pour progresser, pour avancer
dans quelque domaine que ce soit,
je vous le dis, des simples relations amicales jusqu'aux professionnelles,
il faut sortir forcément de sa zone de confort.
On est obligé de passer par une étape où on perd ses repères
pour en recréer des nouveaux plus larges.
C'est aussi pour ça qu'il faut faire des changements progressifs.
Il faut limiter les risques.
Le but est pas forcément de tout plaquer du jour au lendemain.
Une des astuces essentielle pour réussir à élargir sa zone de confort,
c'est qu'il faut pas trop écouter les autres.
Ça veut pas dire qu'il faut pas écouter les conseils constructifs.
Ça veut pas dire qu'il faut non plus absolument appliquer tous les conseils qu'on vous donne.
Mais, de base, n'écoutez pas les gens qui veulent
vous en dissuader pour vous en dissuader.
En fait, ça les renvoie à leur propre image de eux qui n'osent pas prendre des risques.
Ça veut donc dire qu'il faut croire en soi
Et même si vous avez pas une confiance absolue en vous,
le fait de tenter le coup, et de réussir, parce que vous réussirez,
ça vous permettra d'élargir votre zone
mais aussi de prendre confiance en vous.
Dites-vous bien que si vous pensez quelque chose ou faire ce quelque chose,
que vous n'osez pas sortir de voter zone de confort,
quelqu'un le fera à votre place.
Alors pourquoi pas vous directement ?
Dans l'absolu je vous recommande d'assumer vos ambitions,
quelles qu'elles soient.
On a le droit d'avoir des buts et des objectifs dans la vie,
et on a le droit aussi de les assumer,
aussi bien verbalement que dans les actes.
Identifiez votre zone de confort globale :
Où est-ce que je vis ? Dans quel environnement ?
Pourquoi ? Dans quel but ?
Qu'est-ce que je fais pour me divertir ?
Qu'est-ce que je mange ?
Est-ce que je pratique du sport ?
Passez tout en revue,
déterminez ce qui vous ferait plaisir d'explorer,
sortez de votre zone, faites votre exploration,
et au final vous verrez que vous aurez élargi votre zone de confort.
L'exploration ça peut ête juste essayer d'élargir vos activités,
en en pratiquant des nouvelles.
Ça peut être en fréquentant des nouvelles personnes d'un nouveau milieu.
Ça peut être aussi en déménageant,
peut-être même en déménageant dans un autre pays.
L'idéal pour ça c'est de se lancer des défis.
Et vous comprenez que c'est exactement ce que j'ai fais cette année.
Et je voudrais faire un parallèle sur le mot "confort" et "zone de confort",
c'est-à-dire que de base, en France, on est,
dans la naissance je parle, dans une belle zone de confort.
La plupart d'entre-nous ont un toit, ont à manger, ont de quoi s'habiller.
Dans la pyramide des besoins, on est plutôt bien placés,
et on peut décider et choisir nous-même de sortir de notre zone de confort
pour pouvoir l'élargir un petit peu plus.
On a ce luxe là.
C'est pas le cas de tout le monde, hein,
si on veut parler un petit peu de chiffres,
il y a 60 millions de personnes dans le monde
qui ont été déplacées contre leur gré,
qu'on été arraché de là où ils habitaient,
qu'on force à être à un endroit précis
et qui n'ont aucun moyen de réaliser leurs rêves, leurs ambitions
et parfois même leur propre quotidien,
dont 30 millions d'enfants, sur les 60 millions.
Je parle d'eux c'est pas un hasard c'est parce que
le 20 juin prochain c'est la journée mondiale des réfugiés.
Il va y avoir une grande campagne là-dessus dont le but c'est de récolter des fonds évidemment
mais en priorité, par exemple pour vous qui regardez la vidéo,
de vous sensibiliser aussi à ça et à cette réalité là
en fait de 60 millions de personnes pour qui élargir la zone de confort
voudrait dire avoir déjà une zone de confort personnelle.
Je vais vous mette un lien dans le descriptif qui vous permettra
d'aller sur le site.
Je voulais pas le préciser et puis je le précise quand même,
je ne perçoit rien et ne gagne rien à faire ça, je voulais juste vous en parler
parce que le sujet de cette vidéo, que j'avais prévue depuis un petit moment
faisait un vrai écho avec cette réalité là.
Et il y a une coalition humanitaire qui est partie à la base du Canada
qui vise à aider toutes ces familles là et ces 60 millions de personnes,
et je pense que vous l'avez maintenant compris, je soutiens à 100%
cette journée mondiale pour les réfugiés qui a lieu le 20 juin
et toute la campagne qu'il y a autour.
Donc c'était important pour moi de vous en parler comme ça en quelques mots.
Pour en terminer avec notre sujet, pensez à vous donner des défis,
pensez à élargir votre zone à vous.
Il y a une phrase qui dit :
"Le mouvement c'est la vie." J'irai plus loin en disant
"L'exploration d'autres zones c'est la vie."
*miaulement*
Y a Tamalo à la fenêtre qui me dit qu'il faut conclure.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu, que vous allez vous donner des petits défis.
Si c'est le cas, n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir en laissant un petit
POUCE EN L'AIR
Vous pouvez également vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir si c'est pas déjà fait, évidemment,
parce que le Mental Vlog, c'est quoi ? C'est une vidéo par jour, pendant un an.
Et peut-être plus, parce que j'ai d'autres projets qui commencent à se dessiner pour l'année prochaine.
Alors rendez-vous demain à 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog.
CIAO !